so my talk will be on recent trends and
minimum of algorithms
so in this talk we'll be considering
various forms of the min cut algorithm
from the min cut problems in graphs
so this is uh given the graph find a
minimum carnality or weight set of edges
whose removal disconnects the graph in
some way
and this way will depend on
the problem the specific problem so for
example the global banker problem all we
need to do is to disconnect the graph
disconnect any two vertices from each
other
for the st makeup problem we are also
given two vertices s and t
and one disconnects those two specific
vertices
and another uh variant which actually
generalizes them above two it's a
steiner main cut so here we're given a
subset of vertices of the terminals and
we just want to disconnect any two
vertices terminals from each other so
for example if the terminal set is just
the the two elements at s and t then
this is just s t min cut
and the terminals are just all the
vertices then this is global
you can also consider problems that
involve computing multiple uh min cuts
for example the single source min cut
problem we're given a source s and we'll
find for all vertices t the min
statement
and finally the the common
generalization of all these problems the
all-person cut find the st mega for all
pairs st
all pairs of vertices
so this talk will be mainly considered
concerned about fast algorithms to solve
these problems
uh one of the most not well-known
results uh well-known theorems the
maximum cut theorem shows that the st
makeup problem can be solved by a single
st max low call
and a recent breakthrough by chennai
showed that this can actually be done in
almost like your time so almost
optimally
the other problems it turns out we can
reduce these problems to the st min cut
problem in particular global steiner and
single sourcement that can be trivially
trivially reduced to n minus 1 calls to
estimate cut which in turn can be
reduced to sc maximum
one of the classic results uh in the
field by gamrie who
showed that all pairs min cut can also
be reduced to n minus one calls so this
is non-trivial because the trivial
reduction will require n squared calls
but they show that only a minus one
calls supplies
but uh for the global mix in particular
karger
devised an arm to solve this problem
without using max flow
and this
this ran in near linear randomized time
so um so based on these uh
known results we can we have a hierarchy
of
the problem complexity of these uh min
cut
problems
um the uh the first group are the all
pairs singles and sine or min cuts they
require n minus one maxwell's
the asthma
is by itself they require a single
maxwell and finally there's a global
minta which is easier than at max flow
it requires just near linear time but
only in the randomized case
we can think of
we can pictorially think of the
hierarchy as we have a group of these
these problems each of them is reduces
to the
each of these uh reduces from the one
before it
and finally we have these two
incomparable
problems st for which we call one max
low and global which require no maximums
but only
for randomized algorithms
so this is the landscape of the min card
problem before our work
and in this talk we'll consider uh we'll
be
serving recent progress uh to
improving upon these higher is
hierarchical problems
so the main question this talk will be
are these
complexities tight or can they be
improved
so um
so one of the first results uh in this
direction was by myself and demoli at
pentagraffy we showed the steiner min
cut in particular can be solved in just
polylogmas uh calls to estimate
so intuitively it just means that
steiner is closer to st min than single
source
so it's um
um
and
at the time this actually gave the so
this the reduction can actually be
randomized and at the time it gave the
fast deterministic algorithm global
income
also the second result in this direction
showed that actually uh if you take to
consider all paraspin cut problems in
the single source spin cut
all pairs can actually be solved using
polylog calls to single assortment so
these problems are essentially
equivalent
of the polyglot factors
and the message behind this result is
that if you want to improve all parasite
cut it suffices to consider just single
source right
and finally a result by myself showed
that global min cut
in particular the card raised algorithm
can be actually randomized
and
um which means that global men can
actually be solved in almost linear time
deterministically
again without much
so based on these three results the new
landscape of the problems look like it
looks like this where steiner has now
moved from
before
from this group to this group where
spiner and st are equivalent up to
polylog factors
and here we have an equivalence
essentially a polylog equivalence
between all-person signal source
and the final question remained what
about this direction here is it is there
a separation between these two groups in
the sense that
these problems cannot be solved
efficiently
more efficiently than these or is this
also the process
so more recently uh just this year
we
have made progress towards this question
um a result by abu krauthammer myself
kindergarten serenorf and trabelsee we
show that single source main cut
can actually be solved in polylog calls
to sc min cut with one caveat which is
it requires additional additive and
square time for weighted graphs for
unweighted graphs this is the mean this
can be removed and this is a very
technical assumption
um it's not intuitive at all why this
factor comes
appears but this is something that
requires is that is um we're trying to
improve to just almost
so um
so with this result
um the landscape is now actually pretty
much flat uh all pairs single source
steiner and st max most xd min cut are
pretty much all within pylons of each
other
the one caveat is there's an n squared
additive factor between these two
problems
between these two groups and of course
global mechanics on its own
both for randomized and deterministic
they
it can be solved without max flow
so all of all these recent results
center around the two key ideas
the first is a problem that a new
problem that we define called minimum
isolating cuts
it's it can be thought of as a new
primitive
to find unbalanced cuts in the graph
the other the other key idea that um
that's driven these this progress
is this this type this technique called
expander decomposition which decomposes
given any graph into expanders
which are much easier to solve for many
cut problems
so for the rest of this talk i'll be
mainly con focusing on the moon
isolating cuts problems uh
since it's a more recent development and
seeing how
this primitive can be used to solve
method problems
so let me first define the midnight sim
cuts problem so given an undirected
graph and a set of terminals
we want to find we want to output for
each terminal the min cut that separates
that terminal from all the other terms
so in other words we're going to find
the cut isolating that terminal from
everyone else
so for example
if this is the graph and the right
variable terminals
then this could be a set of isolated
cuts it turns out the cuts can are
actually disjoint so the
the sides um can be can be assumed to be
constructed
so nice is just simply call sd min cut
for each terminal and this will require
the size of r the number of terminals
many calls to sd min cut
but um
[Music]
but the main result um in this direction
which we call the isolating cuts lemma
show that uh we can actually do much
better we can solve this problem in just
a logarithmic calls so in other words
midnight isolating cuts have the same
complexity roughly as just ethylene
so the this algorithm itself is actually
quite simple like the algorithm proof is
only two pages but unfortunately i won't
have time to go over it instead i'll
show how this
midnight encounters primitive can be
used to solve steiner method in a very
simple way
so recall the signature makeup problem
we just want to disconnect some two
given terminals from each other
and here's the algorithm
we're going to sample the various
probabilities like germany decreasing
probabilities one when i have one fourth
one and so on
and for each of these sampling
probabilities we'll just independently
sample each terminal into a new terminal
set r
so we have our original term set t
for each terminal we independently
sample it into our set r with rate p
and we'll just call midnight and cuts on
r
and finally the mid isolating cusp
primitive gives us a bunch of cuts
um over
each sample for each sampling probably
we'll get a bun we'll get a question
because we'll just output the smallest
isolating cut found over all all these
triads
and that's the algorithm um we'll show
that with good probability this gives
you the sign
for analysis let's assume we uh we know
the sign of income
so let's say it's this set s here
um the key observation is that if we
sample it probably roughly one over the
size of s of course we don't know this
probability but we're trying pretty much
all the probabilities
if we if we sample with this one over
size of s
then they're probably sampling exactly
one vertex in s is a constant
and this is just a simple probability
bound
you can think of in expectation it's
it's one if we sample with probably one
over size of s and this random error was
not too adversarial that um with good
probability we'll have exactly
and this occurs then the spiderman cut
this cut is actually a valid icing okay
and it's easy it can be shown that
um isolating cuts are in fact steiner
cuts so the isolating cut for this
sample terminal will indeed be this time
so that essentially concludes my talk um
future directions
one of the most interesting directions
uh my opinion is directed grass so this
landscape is much less understood
um for example the global med type is
still the complexity of global mecca so
i know
um a recent result by sen myself narayan
kai
showed that this can be done in root and
max those of course is still far from
optimal
um a very interesting question is can
this be done in polylog maxwell's or is
this not
possible what about steiner man it turns
out this is actually surprising it's
hard um there are lower bounds to show
this is there's no support so quadratic
time now you know and part of the
reasons because the midnight inca
technology also fails this is actually a
hard problem directed graphs
finally um
um
what about the expanded composition
technique that i didn't have time to go
over
turns out
it turns out um this can be generalized
directed grass but the guarantees are
much weaker
and one open problem i'm interested in
is can we strengthen the direct expanded
decomposition to hopefully solve let's
say global min cut and faster
that concludes my talk uh feel free to
chat uh
if you're interested in any of these
problems
thanks for the informative talk yeah
maybe uh the next speaker can set up
while let me take a quick question
yep
i mean all those results are for the
worst case analysis of the problem right
just as a first step for a beyond worst
case analysis do we have any results
about the random graph right right
that's a good question so it turns out
random graphs are expanders
with high probability so it turns out um
in particular this technique of expanded
decomposition which says that
um expanders are easy and for general
graphs would be composure expanders it
turns out um this technology
applies directly to random graphs
i see
they're actually much easier than
and just to to see the
to connect the line so we believe that
also the smooth analysis could be easy
given that
the one the smooth analysis
smooth analysis yeah um
uh
i'm not sure i think like
uh
yeah because this the price this problem
is very combinatorial so i'm not sure
what smoothness means
just to close it so do we believe that
there is an open question for the random
graphs or it is more or less i think
it's more or less solved because random
guys are expanders which are much easier
than general graphs i see thank you
let's take any other questions in the
break
and go to the next talk